j'ai eu un gros accident voilà mine de
rien isabelle vous non en voiture jamais
on n'a eu dé dieu merci quelques de
l'année un jour à lire le cheval qui
s'est cabré comme ça non mais je vous
dis dans mes réponses européenne ue a
sinon en voiture mois en sortant deux en
sortant du foot je sortais de
l'entraînement et j'avais racheté la
voiture d'un joueur de foot du paris
saint germain
non ouais j'avais mis cinquante mille
francs en étant frais les moyens c'est
une renault 25 baccarat non bâti et
auquel sauver la renault 25 baccalauréat
en 97 et en fait je sors à maisons
laffitte et ya un mec qui arrive en audi
80 et on fait un face à face dont la
mélodie 80 a fait un tonneau moi j'étais
dans l'autre sens j'avais la clé de
voiture dans le genou j'ai fait du coma
j'ai fait ce n'est des pompiers ont dit
l'accident que vous avez fait là c'est
sur autoroute normalement mais les
photos de la boîte et les deux voitures
sont pliés si tu roules à combien est
maintenant moi je roulais à 50 que je
sors du lot mais non mais moi je sortais
de maisons laffitte et mais l'arrivée de
sartrouville et en face à face et
maintenant ils ont fait un rond point
ils ont fait ils emménagent élise il
paraît qu'il rappelait le rond-point
foden c'est fou maxime danghin dieu
comme j'ai pas le permis je touche du
bois
c'est normal normalement je me suis fait
un accident tout seul a les pieds
nickelés
suivez moi l'art et je me suis fait un
traumatisme crânien et d'une double
fracture du bassin oui ça doit être ça
mathis crânien je suis tombé à la
piscine l'échelle non j'ai tapé
l'échelle en fonte à l'attentât piscine
dernière on regarde de connaissances le
bras dans l'homélie très les portes et
vous mais vous vous êtes à l'hôpital
non dans le xème la l'hôpital
saint-louis spéciale de la tête j'avais
plus de 100 lits porté sur yon vous avez
été porté par elie semoun et non les
commentaires j'avais 12 ans la piscine
jean a mis en gage avait 9 ans il a même
placé il ya eu un accident
we went wrong de j'étais jeune j'avais
je suis là c'était une deuxième démarque
une 205 gti c'était ma fierté c'est avec
mon premier salaire je m'étais acheté ça
pour essayer de pêcher les meufs et je
rentrais de nancy pour la epinal de nuit
parce que je travaillais finale le
lendemain et il faisait tellement dormi
c'est au volant
il chauffe pas trop fort et de sourires
des enfants dormaient sur normes et les
corriger ou celle du cerveau la fête les
cerveaux adobe touch apps avec ça c'est
sûr hormis ces deux derniers souvenirs
en hiver je sais c'est dans le c'était
dans le voiture je produis sait et il
faisait froid et dernier souvenir que
j'essaie je tapais les poteaux say de
ray faire réfléchir photos sont son
temps à ce trailer de la route et j'ai
fait des tonneaux et j'avais j'ai marché
jusque le village suivant gtalk et une
poche je le fais vite ouvre parce que je
voyais des demies à travers les allées
les poules et eau chaude ou ma fille et
pour la femme subit pour déshabiller que
c'est pas de bol le marité juste
derrière ils m'ont ramené à la maison
après si le chrétien j'allège aller au
boulot allez vous remercie kelly rowland
on sait pas si on a déjà des clots
moments difficiles